[موسيقى]
مرحبا ضجه كبيره يثيرها حاليا مسلسل
التونسي الجبل الاحمر اللي يحكي قصص
واقعيه التقى فيها مخرج العمل اما
باصحابها او اقاربهم او اصدقائهم حيث امضت
ورشه كتابه المسلسل اربعه اشهر شارك فيها
كتاب معروفين ومؤرخين ايضا هو مسلسل عشرين
حلقه
من 45 دقيقه
فيه عدد كبير من النجوم تقريبا 70 من
سبعين الى 80% من الكاستينغ هما نجوم صف
اول توانسه مسلسل
اجتماعي
تشويق واثاره لما هي الشخصيه فيها تلوينات
فيها تضاريس فيها
اشياء منتظره كما انه فيها اشياء غير
منتظره تماما هي مثل الشخصيات تراجيديه او
شخصيات الملحميه اللي تعيش تجربه
بدايه
وفي الواقع هي ككل الشخصيات
الموجوده بيناتنا كذلك
تميزها تجربتها الخاصه المسلسل الاجتماعي
مع نهايه الاسبوع
الثامن وحكاياتها على مستوى المضمون جبال
الاحمر يقوم على اهم عناصر الدراما اللي
هما مثلث السلطه والحب والموت وهو يحاكي
ويقع
الاحياء الشعبيه
وتناول موضوع من اهم المواضيع الشركه في
وقتنا هذا اللي هو ظاهره الفساد الفساد
اللي عنده اوجه متعدده فساد قيامه فساد
معنوي فساد سياسي وانعكاسات على حياه
الاحياء الشعبيه كتابه الشخصيات في هذا
المجال كتبت بشكل واقعي تجد عن نفس
الشخصيه جانب جيد وجانب قد يكون سيء او
جانب متسامح وقد يوجد في لحظه من اللحظات
جانب عنيف وهو واقعي جدا
فساعدنا سيناريو في بناء الشخصيات متاعنا
المخرج ربي يقول انه فكره المسلسل انطلقت
لحظه امراه ماما موقف غريب كان ضحيه هذا
موقف شهاب تمت معاملته بشكل سيء فقط لانه
ينتمي للحياه الشعبي اللي تدور فيه احداث
العمل رجاء مسلسل الجبل الاحمر ليسال
لماذا
مبروك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات